The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I'm using
a few things here, right?
I'm using the fact that
KL is non-negative.
But KL is equal to 0 when I
take twice the same argument.
So I know that this function
is always non-negative.
So that's theta and that's
KL P theta star P theta.
And I know that at theta
star, it's equal to 0.
OK?
I could be in the case
where I have this happening.
I have two-- let's call
it theta star prime.
I have two minimizers.
That could be the case, right?
I'm not saying
that-- so K of L--
KL is 0 at the minimum.
That doesn't mean that I
have a unit minimum, right?
But it does, actually.
What do I need to
use to make sure
that I have only one minimum?
So the definiteness
is guaranteeing to me
that there's a unique P
theta star that minimizes it.
But then I need to
make sure that there's
a unique-- from this
unique P theta star,
I need to make sure there's
a unique theta star that
defines this P theta star.
Exactly.
All right, so I
combine definiteness
and identifiability to make
sure that there is a unique
minimizer, in this
case cannot exist.
OK, so basically, let me
write what I just said.
So definiteness, that
implies that P theta star
is the unique minimizer of P
theta maps to KL P theta star P
theta.
So definiteness only
guarantees that the probability
distribution is
uniquely identified.
And identifiability
implies that theta star
is the unique minimizer of
theta maps to KL P theta star P
theta, OK?
So I'm basically
doing the composition
of two injective functions.
The first one is the one that
maps, say, theta to P theta.
And the second one is
the one that maps P theta
to the set of minimizers, OK?
So at least morally, you
should agree that theta star
is the minimizer of this thing.
Whether it's unique
or not, you should
agree that it's a good one.
So maybe you can think
a little longer on this.
So thinking about this
being the minimizer,
then it says,
well, if I actually
had a good estimate
for this function,
I would use the strategy
that I described
for the total
variation, which is,
well, I don't know what
this function looks like.
It depends on theta star.
But maybe I can
find an estimator
of this function that
fluctuates around this function,
and such that when I minimize
this estimator of the function,
I'm actually not too far, OK?
And this is exactly what
drives me to do this,
because I can actually
construct an estimator.
I can actually construct
an estimator such
that this estimator
is actually--
of the KL is actually
close to the KL, all right?
So I define KL hat.
So all we did is just replacing
expectation with respect
to theta star by averages.
That's what we did.
So if you're a little puzzled by
this error, that's all it says.
Replace this guy by this guy.
It has no mathematical meaning.
It just means just
replace it by.
And now that actually tells
me how to get my estimator.
It just says, well,
my estimator, KL hat,
is equal to some constant
which I don't know.
I mean, it certainly
depends on theta star,
but I won't care about it
when I'm trying to minimize--
minus 1/n sum from i from
1 to n log f theta of x.
So here I'm reading
it with the density.
You have it with the
PMF on the slides,
and so you have the two
versions in front of you, OK?
Oh sorry, I forgot the xi.
Now clearly, this function
I know how to compute.
If you give me a theta, since
I know the form of the density
f theta, for each
theta that you give me,
I can actually compute
this quantity, right?
This I don't know,
but I don't care.
Because I'm just shifting
the value of the function
I'm trying to minimize.
The set of minimizers
is not going to change.
So now, this is my
estimation strategy.
Minimize in theta KL hat
P theta star P theta, OK?
So now let's just make sure
that we all agree that--
so what we want is the
argument of the minimum,
right? arg min means the
theta that minimizes this guy,
rather than finding
the value of the min.
OK, so I'm trying to find
the arg min of this thing.
Well, this is equivalent
to finding the arg
min of, say, a constant minus
1/n sum from i from 1 to n
of log f theta of xi.
So that's just--
I don't think it likes me.
No.
OK, so thus minimizing
this average, right?
I just plugged in the
definition of KL hat.
Now, I claim that
taking the arg min
of a constant plus a function
or the arg min of the function
is the same thing.
Is anybody not comfortable
with this idea?
OK, so this is the same.
By the way, this
I should probably
switch to the next slide,
because I'm writing
the same thing, but better.
And it's with PMF
rather than as PF.
OK, now, arg min of the minimum
is the same of arg max--
sorry, arg min of
the negative thing
is the same as arg max
without the negative, right?
arg max over theta of 1/n from
i equal equal 1 to n log f
theta of xi.
Taking the arg
min of the average
or the arg min of
the sum, again, it's
not going to make
much difference.
Just adding constants OR
multiplying by constants
does not change the
arg min or the arg max.
Now, I have the
sum of logs, which
is the log of the product.
OK?
It's the arg max of the
log of f theta of x1 times
f theta of x2, f theta of xn.
But the log is a function
that's increasing, so maximizing
log of a function or
maximizing the function itself
is the same thing.
The value is going to
change, but the arg max
is not going to change.
Everybody agrees with this?
So this is equivalent to arg
max over theta of pi from 1 to n
of f theta xi.
And that's because x maps
to log x is increasing.
So now I've gone from
minimizing the KL
to minimizing the
estimate of the KL
to maximizing this product.
Well, this chapter is called
maximum likelihood estimation.
The maximum comes from the
fact that our original idea
was to minimize the
negative of a function.
So that's why it's
maximum likelihood.
And this function here
is called the likelihood.
This function is really
just telling me--
they call it
likelihood because it's
some measure of how
likely it is that theta
was the parameter that
generated the data.
OK, so let's go to the--
well, we'll go to the formal
definition in a second.
But actually, let
me just give you
intuition as to why this is
the distribution of the data.
Why this is the
likelihood-- sorry.
Why is this making sense
as a measure of likelihood?
Let's now think for simplicity
of the following model.
So I have--
I'm on the real line
and I look at n, say,
theta 1 for theta in the
real-- do you see that?
OK.
Probably you don't.
Not that you care.
OK, so--
OK, let's look at
a simple example.
So here's the model.
As I said, we're looking at
observations on the real line.
And they're distributed
according to some n theta 1.
So I don't care
about the variance.
I know it's 1.
And it's indexed by
theta in the real line.
OK, so this is-- the only
thing I need to figure out
is, what is the mean
of those guys, OK?
Now, I have this n observations.
And if you actually remember
from your probability class,
are you familiar with the
concept of joint density?
You have multivariate
observations.
The joint density of
independent random variables
is just a product of their
individual densities.
So really, when I look
at the product from i
equal 1 to n of f
theta of xi, this
is really the joint
density of the vector--
well, let me not use
the word vector--
of x1 xn, OK?
So if I take the product of
density, is it still a density?
And it's actually-- but
this time on the r to the n.
And so now what this
thing is telling me-- so
think of it in r2, right?
So this is the joint
density of two Gaussians.
So it's something that looks
like some bell-shaped curve
in two dimensions.
And it's centered at
the value theta theta.
OK, they both have
the mean theta.
So let's assume for
one second-- it's
going to be hard for me to
make pictures in n dimensions.
Actually, already
in two dimensions,
I can promise you that
it's not very easy.
So I'm actually
just going to assume
that n is equal to 1 for
the sake of illustration.
OK, so now I have this data.
And now I have one
observation, OK?
And I know that the f
theta looks like this.
And what I'm doing
is I'm actually
looking at the value of x
theta as my observation.
Let's call it x1.
Now, my principal tells me,
just find the theta that
makes this guy the most likely.
What is the likelihood of my x1?
Well, it's just the
value of the function.
That this value here.
And if I wanted to find the most
likely theta that had generated
this x1, what I would need
to do is to shift this thing
and put it here.
And so my estimate, my
maximum likelihood estimator
here would be theta
is equal to x1, OK?
That would be just
the observation.
Because if I have
only one observation,
what else am I going to do?
OK, and so it sort
of makes sense.
And if you have
more observations,
you can think of it this way,
as if you had more observations.
So now I have, say,
K observations,
or n observations.
And what I do is that I
look at the value for each
of these guys.
So this value, this value,
this value, this value.
I take their product and
I make this thing large.
OK, why do I take the product?
Well, because I'm trying
to maximize their value
all together, and I need to
just turn it into one number
that I can maximize.
And taking the product
is the natural way
of doing it, either
by motivating it
by the KL principle
or motivating it
by maximizing the joint density,
rather than just maximizing
anything.
OK, so that's why, visually,
this is the maximum likelihood.
It just says that if my
observations are here,
then this guy, this mean theta,
is more likely than this guy.
Because now if I
look at the value
of the function
for this guy-- if I
look at theta being
this thing, then this
is a very small value.
Very small value, very small
value, very small value.
Everything gets a super
small value, right?
That's just the value
that it gets in the tail
here, which is very close to 0.
But as soon as I start
covering all my points
with my bell-shaped curve,
then all the values go up.
All right, so I just want
to make a short break
into statistics,
and just make sure
that the maximum likelihood
principle involves
maximizing a function.
So I just want to
make sure that we're
all on par about how do
we maximize functions.
In most instances, it's going to
be a one-dimensional function,
because theta is going to be
a one-dimensional parameter.
Like here it's the real line.
So it's going to be easy.
In some cases, it may be
a multivariate function
and it might be
more complicated.
OK, so let's just
make this interlude.
So the first thing
I want you to notice
is that if you open any book
on what's called optimization,
which basically is the science
behind optimizing functions,
you will talk mostly--
I mean, I'd say
99.9% of the cases
will talk about
minimizing functions.
But it doesn't matter, because
you can just flip the function
and you just put a minus
sign, and minimizing h
is the same as maximizing
minus h and the opposite, OK?
So for this class,
since we're only
going to talk about maximum
likelihood estimation,
we will talk about
maximizing functions.
But don't be lost if
you decide suddenly
to open a book on optimization
and find only something
about minimizing functions.
OK, so maximizing an arbitrary
function can actually be fairly
difficult. If I give you a
function that has this weird
shape, right-- let's think of
this polynomial for example--
and I wanted to find the
maximum, how would we do it?
So what is the thing you've
learned in calculus on how
to maximize the function?
Set the derivative equal to 0.
Maybe you want to check
the second derivative
to make sure it's a
maximum and not a minimum.
But the thing is, this is only
guaranteeing to you that you
have a local one, right?
So if I do it for this function,
for example, then this guy
is going to satisfy
this criterion,
this guy is going to
satisfy this criterion,
this guy is going to satisfy
this criterion, this guy here,
and this guy satisfies
the criterion, but not
the second derivative one.
So I have a lot of candidates.
And if my function can
be really anything,
it's going to be
difficult, whether it's
analytically by taking
derivatives and setting them
to 0, or trying to find
some algorithms to do this.
Because if my function
is very jittery,
then my algorithm basically
has to check all candidates.
And if there's a lot of them,
it might take forever, OK?
So this is-- I have only
one, two, three, four,
five candidates to check.
But in practice, you might have
a million of them to check.
And that might take forever.
OK, so what's nice about
statistical models, and one
of the things that makes all
these models particularly
robust, and that we
still talk about them 100
years after they've
been introduced
is that the functions
that-- the likelihoods
that they lead
for us to maximize
are actually very simple.
And they all share
a nice property,
which is that of being concave.
All right, so what is
a concave function?
Well, by definition, it's
just a function for which--
let's think of it as being
twice differentiable.
You can define
functions that are not
differentiable as being concave,
but let's think about it
as having a second derivative.
And so if you look
at the function that
has a second derivative,
concave are the functions
that have their second
derivative that's
negative everywhere.
Not just at the
maximum, everywhere, OK?
And so if it's strictly
concave, this second derivative
is actually strictly
less than zero.
And particularly if I
think of a linear function,
y is equal to x,
then this function
has its second derivative
which is equal to zero, OK?
So it is concave.
But it's not
strictly concave, OK?
If I look at the function
which is negative x squared,
what is its second derivative?
Minus 2.
So it's strictly
negative everywhere, OK?
So actually, this is a
pretty canonical example
strictly concave function.
If you want to think of a
picture of a strictly concave
function, think of
negative x squared.
So parabola pointing downwards.
OK, so we can talk about
strictly convex functions.
So convex is just happening when
the negative of the function
is concave.
So that translates into having
a second derivative which
is either non-negative
or positive, depending
on whether you're talking about
convexity or strict convexity.
But again, those
convex functions
are convenient when you're
trying to minimize something.
And since we're trying
to maximize the function,
we're looking for concave.
So here are some examples.
Let's just go
through them quickly.
OK, so the first one is--
so here I made my
life a little uneasy
by talking about the
functions in theta, right?
I'm talking about
likelihoods, right?
So I'm thinking of functions
where the parameter is theta.
So I have h of theta.
And so if I start
with theta squared,
negative theta squared,
then as we said,
h prime prime of theta, the
second derivative is minus 2,
which is strictly negative,
so this function is strictly
concave.
OK, another function is
h of theta, which is--
what did we pick--
square root of theta.
What is the first derivative?
1/2 square root of theta.
What is the second derivative?
So that's theta to
the negative 1/2.
So I'm just picking up
another negative 1/2,
so I get negative 1/4.
And then I get theta to
the 3/4 downstairs, OK?
Sorry, 3/2.
And that's strictly negative
for theta, say, larger than 0.
And I really need to have
this thing larger than 0
so that it's well-defined.
But strictly larger than 0 is
so that this thing does not
blow up to infinity.
And it's true.
If you think about this
function, it looks like this.
And already, the first
derivative to infinity at 0.
And it's a concave function, OK?
Another one is the
log, of course.
What is the
derivative of the log?
That's 1 over theta, where h
prime of theta is 1 over theta.
And the second derivative
negative 1 over theta squared,
which again, is negative if
theta is strictly positive.
Here I define it as--
I don't need to define it to
be strictly positive here,
but I need it for the log.
And sine.
OK, so let's just do one more.
So h of theta is sine of theta.
But here I take it
only on an interval,
because you want to
think of this function
as pointing always downwards.
And in particular, you
don't want this function
to have an inflection point.
You don't want it to
go down and then up
and then down and then up,
because this is not concave.
And so sine is certainly
going up and down, right?
So what we do is we restrict
it to an interval where sine
is actually-- so what does
the sine function looks
like at 0, 0?
And it's going up.
Where is the first
maximum of the sine?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry.
STUDENT: Pi over 2.
PROFESSOR: Pi over 2,
where it takes value 1.
And then it goes down again.
And then that's at pi.
And then I go down again.
And here you see I actually
start changing my inflection.
So what we do is
we stop it at pi.
And we look at this
function, it certainly
looks like a parabola
pointing downwards.
And so if you look at the--
you can check that it actually
works with the derivatives.
So the derivative
of sine is cosine.
And the derivative of
cosine is negative sine.
OK, and this thing between 0
and pi is actually positive.
So this entire thing is
going to be negative.
OK?
And you know, I can come
up with a lot of examples,
but let's just stick to those.
There's a linear
function, of course.
And the find function
is going to be concave,
but it's actually going to
be convex as well, which
means that it's
certainly not going to be
strictly concave or convex, OK?
So here's your standard picture.
And here, if you look
at the dotted line, what
it tells me is that
a concave function,
and the property we're
going to be using
is that if a strictly concave
function has a maximum, which
is not always the case,
but if it has a maximum,
then it actually must be--
sorry, a local maximum,
it must be a global maximum.
OK, so just the fact that
it goes up and down and not
again means that there's only
global maximum that can exist.
Now if you looked, for example,
at the square root function,
look at the entire
positive real line,
then this thing is never
going to attain a maximum.
It's just going to infinity
as x goes to infinity.
So if I wanted to
find the maximum,
I would have to stop
somewhere and say
that the maximum is attained
at the right-hand side.
OK, so that's the beauty about
convex functions or concave
functions, is that
essentially, these functions
are easy to maximize.
And if I tell you a
function is concave,
you take the first
derivative, set it equal to 0.
If you find a point
that satisfies this,
then it must be a
global maximum, OK?
STUDENT: What if
your set theta was
[INAUDIBLE] then couldn't
you have a function that,
by the definition, is concave,
with two upside down parabolas
at two disjoint intervals, but
yet it has two global maximums?
PROFESSOR: So you
won't get them--
so you want the function
to be concave on what?
On the convex cell
of the intervals?
Or you want it to be--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] just
said that any subset.
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
You're right.
So maybe the
definition-- so you're
pointing to a weakness
in the definition.
Let's just say that
theta is a convex set
and then you're good, OK?
So you're right.
Since I actually just said that
this is true only for theta,
I can just take pieces of
concave functions, right?
I can do this, and
then the next one
I can do this, on the
next one I can do this.
And then I would
have a bunch of them.
But what I want is think
of it as a global function
on some convex set.
You're right.
So think of theta
as being convex
for this guy, an interval,
if it's a real line.
OK, so as I said, for
more generally-- so
we can actually define concave
functions more generally
in higher dimensions.
And that will be useful
if theta is not just
one parameter but
several parameters.
And for that, you need to
remind yourself of Calculus II,
and you have generalization of
the notion of derivative, which
is called a gradient, which
is basically a vector where
each coordinate is just the
partial derivative with respect
to each coordinate of theta.
And the Hessian is
the matrix, which
is essentially a generalization
of the second derivative.
I denote it by nabla
squared, but you
can write it the way you want.
And so this matrix
here is taking as entry
the second partial
derivatives of h with respect
to theta i and theta j.
And so that's the ij-th entry.
Who has never seen that?
OK.
So now, being concave here
is essentially generalizing,
saying that a vector
is equal to zero.
Well, that's just setting
the vector-- sorry.
The first order condition
to say that it's a maximum
is going to be the same.
Saying that a function has
a gradient equal to zero
is the same as saying that
each of its coordinates
are equal to zero.
And that's actually
going to be a condition
for a global maximum here.
So to check convexity, we need
to see that a matrix itself
is negative.
Sorry, to check
concavity, we need
to check that a
matrix is negative.
And there is a
notion among matrices
that compare matrix to zero,
and that's exactly this notion.
You pre- and post-multiply
by the same x.
So that works for
symmetric matrices,
which is the case here.
And so you pre-multiply by x,
post-multiply by the same x.
So you have your matrix,
your Hessian here.
It's a d by d matrix if you
have a d-dimensional matrix.
So let's call it--
OK.
And then here I
pre-multiply by x transpose.
I post-multiply by x.
And this has to be non-positive
if I want it to be concave,
and strictly negative if I
want it to be strictly concave.
OK, that's just a
real generalization.
You can check for yourself
that this is the same thing.
If I were in dimension 1,
this would be the same thing.
Why?
Because in dimension 1, pre-
and post-multiplying by x
is the same as
multiplying by x squared.
Because in dimension 1, I can
just move my x's around, right?
And so that would just
mean the first condition
would mean in dimension 1 that
the second derivative times x
squared has to be less
than or equal to zero.
So here I need this for
all x's that are not zero,
because I can take x to be zero
and make this equal to zero,
right?
So this is for x's that
are not equal to zero, OK?
And so some examples.
Just look at this function.
So now I have functions that
depend on two parameters,
theta1 and theta2.
So the first one is--
so if I take theta
to be equal to--
now I need two
parameters, r squared.
And I look at the function,
which is h of theta.
Can somebody tell me
what h of theta is?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Minus
2 theta2 squared?
OK, so let's compute the
gradient of h of theta.
So it's going to be something
that has two coordinates.
To get the first
coordinate, what do I do?
Well, I take the
derivative with respect
to theta1, thinking of
theta2 as being a constant.
So this thing is
going to go away.
And so I get negative 2 theta1.
And when I take the
derivative with respect
to the second part, thinking
of this part as being constant,
I get minus 4 theta2.
That clear for everyone?
That's just the definition
of partial derivatives.
And then if I want
to do the Hessian,
so now I'm going to
get a 2 by 2 matrix.
The first guy here, I take
the first-- so this guy
I get by taking the derivative
of this guy with respect
to theta1.
So that's easy.
So that's just minus 2.
This guy I get by
taking derivative
of this guy with
respect to theta2.
So I get what?
Zero.
I treat this guy as
being a constant.
This guy is also
going to be zero,
because I take the derivative
of this guy with respect
to theta1.
And then I take the derivative
of this guy with respect
to theta2, so I get minus 4.
OK, so now I want to check
that this matrix satisfies
x transpose--
this matrix x is negative.
So what I do is--
so what is x transpose x?
So if I do x transpose delta
squared h theta x, what I get
is minus 2 x1 squared
minus 4 x2 squared.
Because this matrix is diagonal,
so all it does is just weights
the square of the x's.
So this guy is
definitely negative.
This guy is negative.
And actually, if one
of the two is non-zero,
which means that x is
non-zero, then this thing
is actually strictly negative.
So this function is
actually strictly concave.
And it looks like a
parabola that's slightly
distorted in one direction.
So well, I know this might
have been some time ago.
Maybe for some of you might
have been since high school.
So just remind yourself of doing
second derivatives and Hessians
and things like this.
Here's another one
as an exercise.
h is minus theta1
minus theta2 squared.
So this one is going to
actually not be diagonal.
The Hessian is not
going to be diagonal.
Who would like to do
this now in class?
OK, thank you.
This is not a calculus class.
So you can just do it
as a calculus exercise.
And you can do it
for log as well.
Now, there is a nice
recipe for concavity
that works for the second
one and the third one.
And the thing is, if you look
at those particular functions,
what I'm doing is taking, first
of all, a linear combination
of my arguments.
And then I take a concave
function of this guy.
And this is always
going to work.
This is always going to
give me a complete function.
So the computations
that I just made,
I actually never made
them when I prepared those
slides because I don't have to.
I know that if I take a linear
combination of those things
and then I take a concave
function of this guy,
I'm always going to
get a concave function.
OK, so that's an easy way to
check this, or at least as
a sanity check.
All right, and so as I said,
finding maximizers of concave
or strictly concave
function is the same
as it was in the
one-dimensional case.
What I do-- sorry, in
the one-dimensional case,
we just agreed that we
just take the derivative
and set it to zero.
In the high dimensional
case, we take the gradient
and set it equal to zero.
Again, that's
calculus, all right?
So it turns out that
so this is going
to give me equations, right?
The first one is an
equation in theta.
The second one is an equation
in theta1, theta2, theta3,
all the way to theta d.
And it doesn't mean that because
I can write this equation
that I can actually solve it.
This equation might
be super nasty.
It might be like some polynomial
and exponentials and logs equal
zero, or some crazy thing.
And so there's actually,
for a concave function,
since we know there's
a unique maximizer,
there's this theory of convex
optimization, which really,
since those books are
talking about minimizing,
you had to find some
sort of direction.
But you can think of it as the
theory of concave maximization.
And they allow you to
find algorithms to solve
this numerically and
fairly efficiently.
OK, that means fast.
Even if d is of
size 10,000, you're
going to wait for
one second and it's
going to tell you
what the maximum is.
And that's what machine
learning is about.
If you've taken any class
on machine learning,
there's a lot of optimization,
because they have really,
really big problems to solve.
Often in this
class, since this is
more introductory statistics,
we will have a close form.
For the maximum
likelihood estimator
will be saying theta hat
equals, and say x bar,
and that will be the maximum
likelihood estimator.
So just why-- so has anybody
seen convex optimization
before?
So let me just give
you an intuition
why those functions are easy
to maximize or to minimize.
In one dimension, it's actually
very easy for you to see that.
And the reason is this.
If I want to maximize the
concave function, what
I need to do is to be
able to query a point
and get as an answer the
derivative of this function,
OK?
So now I said this is the
function I want to optimize,
and I've been running my
algorithm for 5/10 of a second.
And it's at this point here.
OK, that's the candidate.
Now, what I can ask is,
what is the derivative
of my function here?
Well, it's going
to give me a value.
And this value is going to
be either negative, positive,
or zero.
Well, if it's
zero, that's great.
That means I'm here
and I can just go home.
I've solved my problem.
I know there's a unique
maximum, and that's
what I wanted to find.
If it's positive,
it actually tells me
that I'm on the left
of the optimizer.
And on the left of
the optimal value.
And if it's negative,
it means that I'm
at the right of the
value I'm looking for.
And so most of the convex
optimization methods
basically tell you, well,
if you query the derivative
and it's actually positive,
move to the right.
And if it's negative,
move to the left.
Now, by how much you
move is basically, well,
why people write books.
And in higher dimension, it's
a little more complicated,
because in higher dimension,
thinks about two dimensions,
then I'm only being
able to get in a vector.
And the vector is only
telling me, well, here
is half of the space
in which you can move.
Now here, if you tell
me move to the right,
I know exactly which direction
I'm going to have to move.
But in two dimension,
you're going
to basically tell me, well,
move in this global direction.
And so, of course, I know
there's a line on the floor I
cannot move behind.
But even if you tell me,
draw a line on the floor
and move only to that
side of the line,
then there's many directions
in that line that I can go to.
And that's also why
there's lots of things
you can do in optimization.
OK, but still, putting this
line on the floor is telling me,
do not go backwards.
And that's very important.
It's just telling
you which direction
I should be going always, OK?
All right, so that's
what's behind this notion
of gradient descent
algorithm, steepest descent.
Or steepest descent, actually,
if we're trying to maximize.
OK, so let's move on.
So this course is not about
optimization, all right?
So as I said, the
likelihood was this guy.
The product of f of the xi's.
And one way you
can do this is just
basically the joint distribution
of my data at the point theta.
So now the likelihood,
formerly-- so here
I am giving myself
the model e theta.
And here I'm going to
assume that e is discrete
so that I can talk about PMFs.
But everything
you're doing, just
redo for the sake of yourself
by replacing PMFs by PDFs,
and everything's
going to be fine.
We'll do it in a second.
All right, so the
likelihood of the model.
So here I'm not looking at
the likelihood of a parameter.
I'm looking at the
likelihood of a model.
So it's actually a
function of the parameter.
And actually, I'm
going to make it
even a function of
the points x1 to xn.
All right, so I have a function.
And what it takes as
input is all the points x1
to xn and a candidate
parameter theta.
Not the true one.
A candidate.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to look at the probability
that my random variables
under this
distribution, p theta,
take these exact
values, px1, px2, pxn.
Now remember, if my
data was independent,
then I could actually just
say that the probability
of this intersection is just a
product of the probabilities.
And it would look
something like this.
But I can define likelihood
even if I don't have
independent random variables.
But think of them as
being independent,
because that's all we're going
to encounter in this class, OK?
I just want you to be aware that
if I had dependent variables,
I could still define
the likelihood.
I would have to understand how
to compute these probabilities
there to be able to compute it.
OK, so think of
Bernoullis, for example.
So here is my example
of a Bernoulli.
So my parameter is--
so my model is 0,1 Bernoulli p.
p is in the interval 0,1.
The probability, just
as a side remark,
I'm just going to use the
fact that I can actually
write the PMF of a Bernoulli
in a very concise form, right?
If I ask you what the
PMF of a Bernoulli is,
you could tell me, well,
the probability that x--
so under p, the probability that
x is equal to 0 is 1 minus p.
The probability under p that
x is equal to 1 is equal to p.
But I can be a bit smart and
say that for any X that's
either 0 or 1, the
probability under p
that X is equal to
little x, I can write it
in a compact form as p to the
X, 1 minus p to the 1 minus x.
And you can check that this is
the right form because, well,
you have to check it only
for two values of X, 0 and 1.
And if you plug in 1,
you only keep the p.
If you plug in 0, you
only keep the 1 minus p.
And that's just a trick, OK?
I could have gone
with many other ways.
Agreed?
I could have said,
actually, something like--
another one would be-- which
we are not going to use,
but we could say, well, it's
xp plus and minus x 1 minus
p, right?
That's another one.
But this one is going
to be convenient.
So forget about this
guy for a second.
So now, I said that
the likelihood is just
this function that's computing
the probability that X1
is equal to little x1.
So likelihood is L of X1, Xn.
So let me try to make
those calligraphic so you
know that I'm talking about
smaller values, right?
Small x's.
x1, xn, and then of course p.
Sometimes we even put--
I didn't do it, but
sometimes you can actually
put a semicolon here, semicolon
so you know that those two
things are treated differently.
And so now you have this
thing is equal to what?
Well, it's just the
probability under p
that X1 is little x1 all
the way to Xn is little xn.
OK, that's just the definition.
All right, so now
let's start working.
So we write the
definition, and then we
want to make it look like
something we would potentially
be able to maximize if I were--
like if I take the derivative
of this with respect to p,
it's not very helpful
because I just don't know.
Just want the algebraic
function of p.
So this thing is going
to be equal to what?
Well, what is the first
thing I want to use?
I have a probability of
an intersection of events,
so it's just the product
of the probabilities.
So this is the product from
i equal 1 to n of P, small p,
Xi is equal to little xi.
That's independence.
OK, now, I'm starting to mean
business, because for each P,
we have a closed form, right?
I wrote this as this
supposedly convenient form.
I still have to reveal to
you why it's convenient.
So this thing is equal to--
well, we said that that
was p xi for a little xi.
1 minus p to the 1 minus xi, OK?
So that was just what I wrote
over there as the probability
that Xi is equal to little xi.
And since they all have
the same parameter p, just
have this p that shows up here.
And so now I'm just taking
the products of something
to the xi, so it's this
thing to the sum of the xi's.
Everybody agrees with this?
So this is equal to p
sum of the xi, 1 minus p
to the n minus sum of the xi.
If you don't feel comfortable
with writing it directly,
you can observe
that this thing here
is actually equal to p over
1 minus p to the xi times 1
minus p, OK?
So now when I take
the product, I'm
getting the products
of those guys.
So it's just this guy
to the power of sum
and this guy to the power n.
And then I can rewrite
it like this if I want to
And so now-- well,
that's what we have here.
And now I am in business
because I can still
hope to maximize this function.
And how to maximize
this function?
All I have to do is to
take the derivative.
Do you want to do it?
Let's just take
the derivative, OK?
Sorry, I didn't tell you that,
well, the maximum likelihood
principle is to just maxim-- the
idea is to maximize this thing,
OK?
But I'm not going to
get there right now.
OK, so let's do it maybe for
the Poisson model for a second.
So if you want to do it
for the Poisson model,
let's write the likelihood.
So right now I'm
not doing anything.
I'm not maximizing.
I'm just computing the
likelihood function.
OK, so the likelihood
function for Poisson.
So now I know-- what is my
sample space for Poisson?
STUDENT: Positives.
PROFESSOR: Positive integers.
And well, let me
write it like this.
Poisson lambda, and I'm going
to take lambda to be positive.
And so that means that the
probability under lambda
that X is equal to little
x in the sample space
is lambda to the
X over factorial x
e to the minus lambda.
So that's basically the
same as the compact form
that I wrote over there.
It's just now a different one.
And so when I want to
write my likelihood, again,
we said little x's.
This is equal to what?
Well, it's equal to the
probability under lambda
that X1 is little
x1, Xn is little xn,
which is equal to the product.
OK?
Just by independence.
And now I can write those
guys as being-- each
of them being i equal 1 to n.
So this guy is just this
thing where a plug in Xi.
So I get lambda to the Xi
divided by factorial xi times e
to the minus lambda, OK?
And now, I mean, this
guy is going to be nice.
This guy is not
going to be too nice.
But let's write it.
When I'm going to take the
product of those guys here,
I'm going to pick up lambda
to the sum of the xi's.
Here I'm going to
pick up exponential
minus n times lambda.
And here I'm going to
pick up just the product
of the factorials.
So x1 factorial all the
way to xn factorial.
Then I get lambda,
the sum of the xi.
Those are little xi's.
e to the minus xn lambda.
OK?
So that might be freaky at
this point, but remember,
this is a function we
will be maximizing.
And the denominator here
does not depend on lambda.
So we knew that maximizing this
function with this denominator,
or any other
denominator, including 1,
will give me the same arg max.
So it won't be a problem for me.
As long as it does
not depend on lambda,
this thing is going to go away.
OK, so in the continuous case,
the likelihood I cannot--
right?
So if I would write
the likelihood
like this in the
continuous case,
this one would be equal to what?
Zero, right?
So it's not very helpful.
And so what we do is we
define the likelihood
as the product of
the f of theta xi.
Now that would be a
jump if I told you,
well, just define it
like that and go home
and don't discuss it.
But we know that this is
exactly what's coming from the--
well, actually, I
think I erased it.
It was just behind.
So this was exactly what
was coming from the KL
divergence estimated, right?
The thing that I
showed you, if we
want to follow this
strategy, which
consists in estimating the KL
divergence and minimizing it,
is exactly doing this.
So in the Gaussian case--
well, let's write it.
So in the Gaussian
case, let's see
what the likelihood looks like.
OK, so if I have a
Gaussian experiment here--
did I actually write it?
OK, so I'm going to take mu and
sigma as being two parameters.
So that means that my sample
space is going to be what?
Well, my sample
space is still R.
Those are just my observations.
But then I'm going to
have a N mu sigma squared.
And the parameters
of interest are mu
and R. And sigma squared
and say 0 infinity.
OK, so that's my Gaussian model.
Yes.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, there's no--
I mean, there's no difference.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think the all the slides
I put the curly bracket,
then I'm just being lazy.
I just like those
concave parenthesis.
All right, so let's write it.
So the definition, L xi, xn.
And now I have two parameters,
mu and sigma squared.
We said, by definition,
is the product from i
equal 1 to n of f
theta of little xi.
Now, think about it.
Here we always had
an extra line, right?
The line was to say that the
definition was the probability
that they were all
equal to each other.
That was the joint probability.
And here it could actually have
a line that says it's the joint
probability distribution
of the xi's.
And if it's not
independent, it's
not going to be the product.
But again, since
we're only dealing
with independent observations
in the scope of this class,
this is the only definition
we're going to be using.
OK, and actually,
from here on, I
will literally skip this step
when I talk about discrete ones
as well, because they
are also independent.
Agreed?
So we start with
this, which we agreed
was the definition for
this particular case.
And so now all of you know by
heart what the density of a--
sorry, that's not theta.
I should write it
mu sigma squared.
And so you need to
understand what this density.
And it's product of 1 over
sigma square root 2 pi times
exponential minus
xi minus mu squared
divided by 2 sigma squared.
OK, that's the Gaussian density
with parameters mu and sigma
squared.
I just plugged in this thing
which I don't give you,
so you just have to trust me.
It's all over any book.
Certainly, I mean,
you can find it.
I will give it to you.
And again, you're not
expected to know it by heart.
Though, if you do your homework
every week without wanting to,
you will definitely
use some of your brain
to remember that thing.
OK, and so now, well, I
have this constant in front.
1 over sigma square root
2 pi that I can pull out.
So I get 1 over sigma square
root 2 pi to the power n.
And then I have the product
of exponentials, which we know
is the exponential of the sum.
So this is equal to
exponential minus.
And here I'm going to put
the 1 over 2 sigma squared
outside the sum.
And so that's how
this guy shows up.
Just the product of the density
is evaluated at, respectively,
x1 to xn.
OK, any questions about
computing those likelihoods?
Yes.
STUDENT: Why [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's a typo.
Thank you.
Because I just took it from
probably the previous thing.
So those are
actually-- should be--
OK, thank you for
noting that one.
So this line should say for
any x1 to xn in R to the n.
Thank you, good catch.
All right, so that's
really e to the n, right?
My sample space always.
OK, so what is maximum
likelihood estimation?
Well again, if you go
back to the estimate
that we got, the estimation
strategy, which consisted
in replacing expectation
with respect to theta star
by average of the data
in the KL divergence,
we would try to maximize
not this guy, but this guy.
The thing that we actually
plugged in were not any small
xi's.
Were actually-- the random
variable is capital Xi.
So the maximum
likelihood estimator
is actually taking
the likelihood,
which is a function
of little x's, and now
the values at which it
estimates, if you look at it,
is actually--
the capital X is my data.
So it looks at the
function, at the data,
and at the parameter theta.
That's what the-- so
that's the first thing.
And then the maximum
likelihood estimator
is maximizing this, OK?
So in a way, what it does is
it's a function that couples
together the data,
capital X1 to capital Xn,
with the parameter theta and
just now tries to maximize it.
So if this is just a
little hard for you to get,
the likelihood is
formally defined
as a function of x, right?
Like when I write f of x.
f of little x, I
define it like that.
But really, the only
x arguments we're
going to evaluate
this function at
are always the random
variable, which is the data.
So if you want,
you can think of it
as those guys being not
parameters of this function,
but really, random variables
themselves directly.
Is there any question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE] those
random variables [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: So those are going
to be known once you have--
so it's always the
same thing in stats.
You first design your
estimator as a function
of random variables.
And then once you get
data, you just plug it in.
But we want to think of them
as being random variables
because we want to understand
what the fluctuations are.
So we're going to keep them as
random variables for as long
as we can.
We're going to spit out
the estimator as a function
of the random variables.
And then when we want
to compute it from data,
we're just going to plug it in.
So keep the random variables
for as long as you can.
Unless I give you
numbers, actual numbers,
just those are random variables.
OK, so there might
be some confusion
if you've seen any stats
class, sometimes there's
a notation which says,
oh, the realization
of the random variables
are lower case versions
of the original
random variables.
So lowercase x should be
thought as the realization
of the upper case X. This
is not the case here.
When I write this,
it's the same way
as I write f of x is
equal to x squared, right?
It's just an argument of a
function that I want to define.
So those are just generic x.
So if you correct
the typo that I have,
this should say that this
should be for any x and xn.
I'm just describing a function.
And now the only
place at which I'm
interested in evaluating
that function,
at least for those first n
arguments, is at the capital
N observations random
variables that I have.
So there's actually
texts, there's actually
people doing research on when
does the maximum likelihood
estimator exist?
And that happens when you
have infinite sets, thetas.
And this thing can diverge.
There is no global maximum.
There's crazy things
that might happen.
And so we're actually
always going to be in a case
where this maximum
likelihood estimator exists.
And if it doesn't, then
it means that you actually
need to restrict your
parameter space, capital Theta,
to something smaller.
Otherwise it won't exist.
OK, so another thing is the
log likelihood estimator.
So it is still the
likelihood estimator.
We solved before that
maximizing a function
or maximizing log
of this function
is the same thing, because the
log function is increasing.
So the same thing is
maximizing a function
or maximizing, I don't know,
exponential of this function.
Every time I take an
increasing function,
it's actually the same thing.
Maximizing a function
or maximizing 10 times
this function is the same thing.
So the function x maps to
10 times x is increasing.
And so why do we talk about
log likelihood rather than
likelihood?
So the log of likelihood
is really just--
I mean the log likelihood is
the log of the likelihood.
And the reason is exactly
for this kind of reasons.
Remember, that was
my likelihood, right?
And I want to maximize it.
And it turns out that
in stats, there's
a lot of distributions that look
like exponential of something.
So I might as well just
remove the exponential
by taking the log.
So once I have this
guy, I can take the log.
This is something to
a power of something.
If I take the log, it's
going to look better for me.
I have this thing--
well, I have another
one somewhere, I think,
where I had the Poisson.
Where was the Poisson?
The Poisson's gone.
So the Poisson was
the same thing.
If I took the log,
because it had a power,
that would make my life easier.
So the log doesn't have any
particular intrinsic notion,
except that it's
just more convenient.
Now, that being
said, if you think
about maximizing the KL,
the original formulation,
we actually remove the log.
If we come back
to the KL thing--
where is my KL?
Sorry.
That was maximizing the sum
of the logs of the pi's.
And so then we worked at it by
saying that the sum of the logs
was--
maximizing the sum of
the logs was the same
as maximizing the product.
But here, we're
basically-- log likelihood
is just going backwards in
this chain of equivalences.
And that's just because
the original formulation
was already convenient.
So we went to find
the likelihood
and then coming back to our
original estimation strategy.
So look at the Poisson.
I want to take log here to
make my sum of xi's go down.
OK, so this is my estimator.
So the log of L--
so one thing that
you want to notice
is that the log of L of
x1, xn theta, as we said,
is equal to the
sum from i equal 1
to n of the log of either
p theta of xi, or--
so that's in the discrete case.
And in the continuous
case is the sum
of the log of f theta of xi.
The beauty of this is that you
don't have to really understand
the difference between
probability mass
function and probability
distribution function
to implement this.
Whatever you get,
that's what you plug in.
Any questions so far?
All right, so shall we
do some computations
and check that, actually, we've
introduced all this stuff--
complicate functions,
maximizing, KL divergence,
lot of things-- so that we
can spit out, again, averages?
All right?
That's great.
We're going to able
to sleep at night
and know that there's a really
powerful mechanism called
maximum likelihood
estimator that was actually
driving our intuition
without us knowing.
OK, so let's do this so.
Bernoulli trials.
I still have it over there.
OK, so actually, I
don't know what--
well, let me write it like that.
So it's P over 1 minus P xi--
sorry, sum of the xi's
times 1 minus P is to the n.
So now I want to maximize
this as a function of P.
Well, the first thing
we would want to do
is to check that this
function is concave.
And I'm just going to ask
you to trust me on this.
So I don't want--
sorry, sum of the xi's.
I only want to take the
derivative and just go home.
So let's just take the
derivative of this with respect
to P. Actually, no.
This one was more convenient.
I'm sorry.
This one was slightly
more convenient, OK?
So now we have--
so now let me take the log.
So if I take the log, what I get
is sum of the xi's times log p
plus n minus some of the
xi's times log 1 minus p.
Now I take the
derivative with respect
to p and set it equal to zero.
So what does that give me?
It tells me that sum of the
xi's divided by p minus n
sum of the xi's divided by
1 minus p is equal to 0.
So now I need to solve for p.
So let's just do it.
So what we get is that 1 minus p
sum of the xi's is equal to p n
minus sum of the xi's.
So that's p times n minus sum of
the xi's plus sum of the xi's.
So let me put it on the right.
So that's p times n is
equal to sum of the xi's.
And that's equivalent to p--
actually, I should start
by putting p hat from here
on, because I'm already
solving an equation, right?
And so p hat is equal
to syn of the xi's
divided by n,
which is my xn bar.
Poisson model, as I
said, Poisson is gone.
So let me rewrite it quickly.
So Poisson, the likelihood
in X1, Xn, and lambda
was equal to lambda to
the sum of the xi's e
to the minus n lambda
divided by X1 factorial,
all the way to Xn factorial.
So let me take the
log likelihood.
That's going to
be equal to what?
It's going to tell me.
It's going to be--
well, let me get rid
of this guy first.
Minus log of X1 factorial
all the way to Xn factorial.
That's a constant with
respect to lambda.
So when I'm going to take the
derivative, it's going to go.
Then I'm going to have plus sum
of the xi's times log lambda.
And then I'm going to
have minus n lambda.
So now then, you
take the derivative
and set it equal to zero.
So log L-- well, partial with
respect to lambda of log L,
say lambda, equals zero.
This is equivalent
to, so this guy goes.
This guy gives me sum of the
xi's divided by lambda hat
equals n.
And so that's
equivalent to lambda hat
is equal to sum of the xi's
divided by n, which is Xn bar.
Take derivative, set it equal
to zero, and just solve.
It's a very satisfying
exercise, especially when
you get the average in the end.
You don't have to
think about it forever.
OK, the Gaussian model I'm going
to leave to you as an exercise.
Take the log to get rid
of the pesky exponential,
and then take the derivative
and you should be fine.
It's a bit more--
it might be one more
line than those guys.
OK, so-- well actually,
you need to take
the gradient in this case.
Don't check the second
derivative right now.
You don't have to
really think about it.
What did I want to add?
I think there was
something I wanted to say.
Yes.
When I have a function that's
concave and I'm on, like,
some infinite
interval, then it's
true that taking the derivative
and setting it equal to zero
will give me the maximum.
But again, I might have a
function that looks like this.
Now, if I'm on some finite
interval-- let me go elsewhere.
So if I'm on some
finite interval
and my function looks like
this as a function of theta--
let's say this is
my log likelihood
as a function of theta--
then, OK, there's no
place in this interval--
let's say this is
between 0 and 1-- there's
no place in this interval where
the derivative is equal to 0.
And if you actually
try to solve this,
you won't find a solution which
is not in the interval 0, 1.
And that's actually how
you know that you probably
should not take the
derivative equal to zero.
So don't panic if you
get something that says,
well, the solution is
at infinity, right?
If this function
keeps going, you
will find that
the solution-- you
won't be able to find a
solution apart from infinity.
You are going to see something
like 1 over theta hat
is equal to 0, or
something like this.
So you know that when you've
found this kind of solution,
you've probably made a
mistake at some point.
And the reason is because the
functions that are like this,
you don't find the maximum by
setting the derivative equal
to zero.
You actually just find
the maximum by saying,
well, it's an increasing
function on the interval 0, 1,
so the maximum must
be attained at 1.
So here in this
case, that would mean
that my maximum would be 1.
My estimator would be
1, which would be weird.
So typically here, you have
a function of the xi's.
So one example that you will see
many times is when this guy is
the maximum of the xi's.
And in which case, the
maximum is attained here,
which is the maximum of this.
OK, so just keep in mind--
what I would recommend
is every time
you're trying to take the
maximum of a function,
just try to plot the
function in your head.
It's not too complicated.
Those things are usually
squares, or square roots,
or logs.
You know what those
functions look like.
Just plug them in your
mind and make sure
that you will find a
maximum which really
goes up and then down again.
If you don't, then
that means your maximum
is achieved at the
boundary and you have
to think differently to get it.
So the machinery that consists
in setting the derivative equal
to zero works 80% of the time.
But o you have to be careful.
And from the context,
it will be clear
that you had to be careful,
because you will find
some crazy stuff, such
as solve 1 over theta hat
is equal to zero.
All right, so
before we conclude,
I just wanted to give you
some intuition about how does
the maximum likelihood perform?
So there's something called
the Fisher information
that essentially controls
how this thing performs.
And the Fisher information
is, essentially,
a second derivative
or a Hessian.
So if I'm in a one-dimensional
parameter case, it's a number,
it's a second derivative.
If I'm in a multidimensional
case, it's actually a Hessian,
it's a matrix.
So I'm going to actually take
in notation little curly L
of theta to be the
log likelihood, OK?
And that's the log likelihood
for one observation.
So let's call it x generically,
but think of it as being x1,
for example.
And I don't care
of, like, summing,
because I'm actually going to
take expectation of this thing.
So it's not going to be
a data driven quantity
I'm going to play with.
So now I'm going
to assume that it
is twice differentiable,
almost surely, because it's
a random function.
And so now I'm going to
just sweep under the rug
some technical conditions
when these things hold.
So typically, when can I
permute integral and derivatives
and this kind of stuff that
you don't want to think about?
OK, the rule of
thumb is it always
works until it
doesn't, in which case,
that probably means
you're actually solving
some sort of calculus problem.
Because in practice,
it just doesn't happen.
So the Fisher information
is the expectation of the--
that's called the outer product.
So that's the product
of this gradient
and the gradient transpose.
So that forms a matrix, right?
That's a matrix minus the outer
product of the expectations.
So that's really what's
called the covariance matrix
of this vector, nabla
of L theta, which
is a random vector.
So I'm forming the covariance
matrix of this thing.
And the technical conditions
tells me that, actually,
this guy, which depends
only on the Hessian,
is actually equal to negative
expectation of the-- sorry.
It depends on the gradient.
Is actually negative
expectation of the Hessian.
So I can actually
get a quantity that
depends on the second
derivatives only using
first derivatives.
But the expectation is
going to play a role here.
And the fact that it's a log.
And lots of things
actually show up here.
And so in this case,
what I get is that--
so in the one-dimensional
case, then this
is just the covariance matrix of
a one-dimensional thing, which
is just a variance of itself.
So the variance
of the derivative
is actually equal to
negative the expectation
of the second derivative.
OK, so we'll see that next time.
But what I wanted to emphasize
with this is that why do
we care about this quantity?
That's called the
Fisher information.
Fisher is the founding
father of modern statistics.
Why do we give this
quantity his name?
Well, it's because this quantity
is actually very critical.
What does the second
derivative of a function
tell me at the maximum?
Well, it's telling me
how curved it is, right?
If I have a zero second
derivative, I'm basically flat.
And if I have a very high second
derivative, I'm very curvy.
And when I'm very
curvy, what it means
is that I'm very robust
to the estimation error.
Remember our
estimation strategy,
which consisted in replacing
expectation by averages?
If I'm extremely curvy,
I can move a little bit.
This thing, the maximum,
is not going to move much.
And this formula here--
so forget about the matrix
version for a second--
is actually telling me exactly--
it's telling me the curvature
is basically the variance
of the first derivative.
And so the more the first
derivative fluctuates,
the more your maximum is
actually-- your org max
is going to move
all over the place.
So this is really
controlling how flat
your likelihood, your log
likelihood, is at its maximum.
The flatter it is, the more
sensitive to fluctuation
the arg max is going to be.
The curvier it is, the
less sensitive it is.
And so what we're
hoping-- a good model
is going to be one that
has a large or small value
for the Fisher information.
I want this to be--
small?
I want it to be large.
Because this is the
curvature, right?
This number is
negative, it's concave.
So if I take a
negative sign, it's
going to be something
that's positive.
And the larger this thing,
the more curvy it is.
Oh, yeah, because
it's the variance.
Again, sorry.
This is what--
OK.
Yeah, maybe I should not
go into those details
because I'm actually
out of time.
But just spoiler alert,
the asymptotic variance
of your-- the variance,
basically, as n
goes to infinity of the
maximum likelihood estimator
is going to be 1 over this guy.
So we want it to be large,
because the asymptotic variance
is going to be very small.
All right, so we're out of time.
We'll see that next week.
And I have your
homework with me.
And I will actually turn it in.
I will give it to
you outside so we
can let the other room come in.
OK, I'll just leave you the--